say adios obrigado por esta gia porous
rock cow roberto cacao was working days
starts with a prayer he compares his
profession to religious service he's a
doctor
Jacinta swapper is a source on soul in
Brazil is a religious country dr.
cacahuate doesn't have a posh doctor's
office in some polo but travels to where
he's needed most with his mobile medical
center as part of the CEA's project at
the moment he and his colleagues are in
san matias a poor district on the
outskirts of the city treating locals in
a mobile clinic
this morning cacao will perform 40
gastroscopy
making sure in each case to take plenty
of time to get to know the person behind
the patient that approach is central to
his project
the fatal dissection may leave feelings
and the soul body and spirit and those
things all go together
that's what doctors are there for to
take everything into consideration not
just the illness if you do that you're
contributing to change to transformation
sorry my purse for myself cacao would
like to shake up Brazil's healthcare
system and make it more humane here
where people wait months and even years
for appointments his earlier is
well-received
vanozza
Alfredo Pereira de Souza is familiar
with the waiting game but now it's her
turn with very little preamble she gets
to see a specialist who examines her
thyroid
people in San Mateo's are not used to
being treated so well there are a few
doctors and no specialists in the
densely populated area
Vanessa's husband has felt the absence
of medical professionals acutely in 2010
she says he slipped a disc and takes out
his x-ray pictures to prove it but he's
not being treated for four years
the cured Theo and the orthopedic doctor
told my husband to go to the neurologist
but there isn't one I have now
registered a complaint but I was told
the examination reports are too old so
now we have to start from the beginning
again but there is another way and that
is CS which has the backing of Brazil
state system the health authorities send
people to CS sites and pay for their
treatment the service offered by the
organization is a welcome means of
helping to shave a couple of months of
long waiting times people have to wait
here - but not for long they are given
appointments and receive their diagnosis
immediately I think we're reinventing
the healthcare system to create one in
which both structures and a human
approach can be brought together a well
balanced mix of the medical staff
technology and organization cacao wood
was born in Brazil but raised in the
Japanese tradition
he says his work requires both Japanese
discipline and Brazilian warmth
having watched his father fight a losing
battle against cancer he decided to
become a doctor and to improve the
health system in his birth country but
he says the problem is a global one
my journal stem was all mortgaged a such
a big low HP source there are some 7
billion people on this planet how many
of them do you think have access to
health care only 5% of the entire
population of the world and what about
the rest
CS helps 2,500 people every day the
organization now has 25 mobile units and
there are more in the making the
containers earmarked to become high-tech
medical centers are not very big it's
essential to make the best use of every
centimeter without compromising hygiene
requirements a fully equipped medical
truck costs an average of 600 thousand
euros which is approximately a tenth of
Cocoa's organization's annual budget
most of his funding comes from the state
but he also receives support from
private companies and sponsors who
contribute money or technology cacao was
latest idea is to put an operating table
and an examination room in a single unit
2/3 of Brazilians are dependent on the
state health system very few people can
afford private health insurance a luxury
some dare not to even dream of
for Sears to expand it will take more
than just the latest technology and
mobile medical centers the organization
depends on team spirit and the genuine
desire to help people neither of which
money can buy Robert kekaula knows that
the road he has chosen to travel is a
tough one but when he's with his
patients he also knows it's worth the
effort